welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in the release of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is so so close but before
we learn the final fate of our beloved
Guardians we thought it might be fun to
get in our last second predictions to
what we think might happen in this final
installment of the trilogy so join me
and some of the other familiar faces
from new rockstars as we place our bets
before the final die is cast on volume
three
everyone's saying rocket and I say he
lives he's an animated character why
would they get rid of him made him
around who are they gonna kill they're
gonna kill Drax baby and I think
Star-Lord could be looking at a demise
here and I think we're gonna kill Gamora
again those three Drax Star-Lord Gamora
gone well Drax Drax is the obvious
answer right everyone's given that one
I'm gonna say that one too has anyone
had the cajones to say Peter Quill they
have
you know what well I'm the one with the
least Stakes so I'm gonna have the
cajones too and I'm saying Star Wars
going down in this one am I super
confident doesn't matter I guess that's
what I'm guessing I think Drax is gonna
die I think cragland might die just
because you know if James Gunn is
leaving this franchise so is Sean Gunn
and because Marvel always kills off
their villains I think Herbert windham's
gonna die I believe that craglin is the
most likely to die in gargan Street
simply because James gun likes to kill
his brother in movies I feel like it's
gonna be rocket I'm also bad at guessing
these things if it's not Rocky then it's
probably Lila so I'll put like five
chips towards rocket 20 towards Lila
well I'll tell you right now there's two
deaths rocket and Drax Baby R and D bye
bye I think that rocket is gonna die and
I think that Drax is gonna die all of
the rocket stuff in the trailers has
been really sad and I cried for 25
minutes this morning when I watched the
one of him naming himself to me that
just says Dead Guy Drax Dave Batista is
leaving so it just made sense to kill
him off
you know I think we could see Thor show
up a little one for one the guardian
show up in Thor's movie I think the war
could show up again I think it would
also be a lot of fun to see erishem does
that count uh Celestial showing up I
think that could be a cameo we see in
this movie um Howard the dog is
obviously is pretty much a done deal
however the duck always shows up well
Howard the Duck is gonna show up but
that's not really a surprise Cameo I
would say he's done all of these I think
we might see Michael Rooker as some form
of yondu either a ghost or in a memory a
flashback of some kind some kind of
recording of himself but I think the
surprise twist is a Benicio del Toro is
going to show up as tanelier Tavon The
Collector Kevin Bacon no if it's not
Kevin Bacon if we're not Kevin in that
bacon I'm gonna say Wonder Man oh an MCU
surprise Cameo coming in from what to
The Watcher number one Madison and Wong
they could come back they could come
back hard and fast and together two hip
and arrows man what happened to those
guys we saw them so long ago what
happened where'd they go what's up they
could come back they're in space
probably I don't know they're three
doctor strange and his freaky little
forehead eye maybe with Charlize Theron
maybe not
I think we're gonna get a surprise
appearance from an 80s icon so around
today but really at the height in the
80s Arnold Schwarzenegger baby Sylvester
Stallone put in a call Schwarzenegger is
going to show up in this movie either as
himself or as like a weird alien you
know I'm rooting for Kevin Bacon to come
back come on back Kevin Bacon if it's if
it's any time it's now again I mean it
was also for the holiday special but
it's now again well Kevin Bacon showed
up in the Guardians holiday special they
shot that around the same time they were
shooting Guardians volume 3 but I think
since this is the last of this Trilogy
Alyssa Milano's got to make a cameo here
Joan Jett is she dead is Joan Jett dead
I don't think Joan jett's dead but I'll
say Joan Jett we're gonna get payoffs
for all the babes the ships have been
named after Pat Benatar Alyssa Milano
coming in hot Molly Ringwald Matthew
Broderick or Pamela Anderson baby
I think in this movie we're gonna get a
reference to He-Man and the Masters of
the Universe yeah the high evolutionary
he's got that like gray Skull action
going on I think Peter will make like a
nice He-Man and the Masters of the
Universe thing all these animal people
running around he would have seen that
before he got abducted I don't know
they're going to a planet with a bunch
of animals imma say sneaked Animal Farm
reference in there Footloose there's no
way the Footloose doesn't get reference
Kevin Bacon is always on Peter Quill's
mind the only movies Peter knows are
ones in the 80s and it tends not to be
the big hits it tends to be just weird
shows that he watched but since we've
had warlock in this he's a character
gets cocooned I wonder if we'll get a
reference to the Ron Howard movie Cocoon
oh my God they'll find a shake way so
when they're on that like Animal Planet
that the higher revolutionary makes I
think we're gonna get a reference to
eight track and specifically songs on a
track like Redbone come and get your
love I think that we are going to go
through the very sad discovery that
Star-Lord has when he realizes that the
lead singer of Nirvana Kurt Cobain is
dead now now he has a Zune he's gonna
get into Nirvana there's no way he can't
it's a 90s staple and I think he's going
to be real bummed out music has always
been such an important part of the
Guardians of the Galaxy films and nerd
Riot's new awesome mix merch collection
has taken that idea and run with it they
have matched up iconic album art with
the Guardians themselves it's the
perfect gear to wear opening weekend or
while rocking out in your daily life
never mind whether or not you grew up on
grunge you could get grunge Groot but if
all the stars have been feeling more
like Ziggy Stardust then the Ziggy
Star-Lord T might be what you need if
you like Dark Side of the Moon then
you'll love this dark side of the Galaxy
T meanwhile I'm rocking my all-time
favorite Rock album Rumors by Fleetwood
Mac cause I can never break the chain
and I'm wearing this rumors inspired
ravager's shirt highly recommend you
grab one shopping at nerd Riot is one of
the best ways to support our Channel and
in addition to tons more Guardians
merged you can find merch inspired by
the MCU Star Wars DC all your favorite
fandoms to get your hands on the merch
you need head to nerd riot.shop today
join the Ryan over at nerd riot.shop
one of the post-credits scenes is going
to be Adam Warlock flying through space
just sailing around and he Zips by a
kind of familiar looking ship that we've
seen recently containing our boy Star
Fox that's right Eros we're gonna see
some of the eternals Adam warlock's
gonna come on the ship and be like this
is my ship now where are we going I want
to hang out with you guys I might go
safe and just say it'll have an Avenger
in it does that count I honestly Cosmo
the space dog is going to be featured
heavily in one of the post-credits a
post-credits scene will introduce us
into the broader Marvel Cosmic Landscape
and we will meet the herald of Galactus
Silver Surfer and the implication that
Galactus will arrive since we know the
setting of nowhere is coming back I
think it'd be interesting if nowhere
just gets devoured by Galactus or that
weird fleshy structure that factory that
they go to might just be some of the
crumbs or scraps of what Galactus had
eaten in the past I believe that there's
a chance that we could see the birth of
either um Adam warlock's evil
counterpart the Magus or the beginnings
of Richard Ryder Nova I think one of the
post credit scenes will be the collector
and will be on earth one of the
post-credits scenes is going to be the
Silver Surfer Moon Knight is just gonna
appear and go
at the end of this movie the leader of
the Guardians of the Galaxy is gonna be
nebula this is gonna be her full Arc of
story from True bad all the way
believing everything her father said all
the way to being true good leading the
Guardians being the one stepping up and
taking charge of the Guardians of the
Galaxy if I'm sticking to my guns that
Star-Lord is gonna die I'm gonna say Mr
Adam
really confidently I'm saying that I
think the leaders of the Guardians will
be nebula and or rocket I think Rocket's
gonna survive this movie but I think
nebula is going to step up as a leader
of the gang oh I think it's gonna be
mantis it'll probably be still Star-Lord
but I wanted to be mantis my best bet is
that mantis will end up being the new
Star-Lord at the end of Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. at the end of the movie
It's ladies night folks mantis nebula
and Gamora will be leading a newly
formed Guardians of the Galaxy I think
that nebula is gonna lead the Guardians
at the end of the movie I think it would
be kind of cool because she was in the
beginning like the most reluctant member
of the Guardians to join and then she
finally did that was like her big
character development was finally
realizing that these people are her
family so I think it would be cool if we
saw her carry the Baton forward
of the current Guardians who will still
be on the team if we consider nebula to
be a guardian then she'll still be on
the team I think cragun will still be
there I think Rocket and Groot will both
be gone I think Rocket and Groot
survived the movie but they leave the
Guardians so of the current members
nebula craglin and mantis that's it you
know anyone who doesn't die is gonna
stick on the team anyone who survives I
feel like a team is gonna stick
so I think nebula and rocket and groups
I think groot's gonna survive because
Groot already has died I think mantis is
going to be around they think Cosmo is
gonna stick around as member of this
group I think all the Guardians will
stay on the Guardians that aren't dead
if Drax or rocket die then the rest of
the Guardians will still be on the team
I think Gamora and nebula will will lead
as sisters I believe mantis will stay on
as kind of the empath dealer of the
group we may see quill going to find
himself after realizing he can't find
his true love with Gamora I think that
along with nebula we are going to have
mantis
because group mantis and nebula go on a
big space journey each other
we are gonna find out so much about
xandar they're gonna stop by zandar it's
gonna be rebuilding still it was
decimated by Thanos probably still
affected by the snap whatever was left
and then the butt people came back but
they got hit first so a lot of the
damage Thanos did to obtain the Power
Stone didn't get undone by the Hulk's
little snap okay Glenn Close possibly
still alive John C Reilly still alive
let's hope he's got a family we're gonna
find out about xandar in this movie
they're gonna answer all our questions
that we had we're not hearing about
xandar in this movie I think yes xandar
has always been home to Reign that James
Gunn specifically has cared most about
of all the MCU directors and in
Guardians of Galaxy Vol 2. we do briefly
see part of the zandarian Empire with
one of the ships of the Nova Corps
overseeing it so it wouldn't surprise me
at all if James can at least addresses
it in this third movie yes I think we'll
explore xandar or at least the cops
Alexander is the police force of the
Galaxy and Guardians are sort of acting
like that in their own way so like these
two police forces are definitely going
to be um clashing or we're running into
each other at some yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if we get a John C Riley and a
Glenn Close Cameo uh at the end of this
movie from the first Guardians to kind
of sew that xandar story line up
together although we do know that Thanos
kind of went old school and called half
the population like maybe if we do find
out about the current state of zandar I
think it'll be in like a couple lines I
don't think we're gonna go to zandar
Peter quell having battled most of his
demons at this point he went back to
Earth briefly but wanted to be back out
in space again he's going to be like you
know what I'm going back to Earth for
real this time I'm hanging it up and
when he tries to go back to Earth Nick
Fury kills him and he's like you can't
be here anymore you gotta go so that's
how Peter Quill dies Nick Fury kills him
and what a sign up for secret Invasion
folks rocket isn't gonna die that's my
twist everyone thinks he's gonna I'm
gonna say he's not so I think we might
end up getting another baby rocker
raccoon like to carry on that Rocket
Raccoon Legacy to hearken back to the
end of Guardians one when the rocket got
a new Groot so Groot will probably get a
new baby rocket well I have talked about
other videos I think the core secret of
this movie is that Celestial blood that
yellow fluid that we see in all these
movies is what is being used to engineer
these beings to endow them with some
kind of Consciousness and sentience and
I think this movie will be the one to
genetically identify everybody with a
Celestial link as a mutant in the Marvel
world and we'll finally get a genetic
definition of mutant kind in this movie
Wild Card big twist is that Gamora winds
up up on Earth and Valentina gets her to
join the Thunderbolts Adam Warlock is
going to kill the higher Revolution
using time travel nebula and Gamora are
gonna go back in time they're gonna
rescue baby rocket and all of his cute
little animal friends before they get
got by the weird scientist man guy and
they're gonna save them and they're just
gonna be cute little babies who grow up
without trauma but because they're
raised by nebula and Gamora they're
still gonna be able to fight and be cool
guys and and it'll be great but in this
timeline they just live normal happy
lives and nobody tortures baby animals
and it's nice so there you go will we be
right will any of our predictions come
true or are our MCU prognostication
skills completely and whack what are
your predictions for the film leave them
in the comments below my live stream
breakdown in Q a of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 will be this Friday May 5th
at noon Eastern on the Deep dive channel
so be sure to subscribe and support us
by grabbing some Guardians of the Galaxy
inspired merch at nerd riot.shop you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow the new Rockstar subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything up thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Applause]